- These 2000 new millennium moms
- [Mark] Treasure, I fucked up.
- Well you fucked up, I'm gonna you up.
- [Mark] (laughing) I'm
going to start all over.
You get me nervous.
- Why I get you nervous?
- [Mark] Cause you're hot.
- I can't help that, I was born like this.
- All right, so we're going to start over.
So we just started, so it's gonna be easy.
- And since I'm that hot,
you might as well take off your clothes
'cause I took off my clothes in the car.
- I'm gonna get your
number before we're done.
- Yeah, it's three, two, three,
four, nine, four, (bleeped).
(both laughing)
- [Mark] All right, Treasure.
Where'd you grow up, Treasure?
- [Treasure] Where did I grow up?
In South Central L.A. at
735. It's called Cali Ma.
My grandmother passed away
while I was giving her a bath.
She was 97 years old.
She passed away at 9:07,
while I was giving her a bath.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- Oh, it was awesome.
- [Mark] You had both your parents?
- I had both my parents,
my mother and my father.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- And both my sets of grandparents.
My mother's mother stayed on
the right side of the street.
And my father's father stayed
on left side of the street
in the two story house
where I stay to this day.
- [Mark] Did having all that family nearby
help you, you think?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Did having all that family--
- Oh yeah, it helped me to
be a strong black woman.
I ain't taking no wooden
nickles, wooden nickles at all.
- [Mark] And so how was
your childhood, happy?
- It was awesome.
For my 12th birthday, I got a pony.
I had a pony for my 12th birthday.
- [Mark] Wow.
- And he finally passed
away when I turned 23,
that was my buddy, and his name was Buddy.
- [Mark] Cool. What
age did you leave home?
- 16.
- [Mark] 16. What kind of
kid were you in high school?
Did you finish high school?
- Oh, I finished high school.
- So you left at 16 and
finished high school?
- Yeah, because I wanted to be on my,
you know, my mom said
if you think you grown,
go out and get on your own,
and I've been on my
own ever since I was 16
and I'll be 52 next month,
and I still live in the home
that my grandparents left me,
and I don't take no mens there
because I'm not married yet,
and I made my grandpa a promise.
If I wasn't, he passed away in 2000,
I told him if I wasn't married,
I don't bring no men to my house.
If you can't go to no hotel,
you cannot get no pussy.
- [Mark] Understood.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And what kind of
kid were you in high school?
- Well, I was a great kid. I ran track.
I was a cheerleader.
- [Mark] So good childhood.
- Yeah, I had a awesome childhood.
- [Mark] And now you're
working the streets.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] On Fig.
- [Mark] When did that start?
- Like, when I was like 23.
I wasn't out there selling
myself just to be selling myself.
I sold myself for my three sons.
- [Mark] You have three kids?
- I have three sons.
- Three boys.
- 34, 32 and 27.
- [Mark] And you raised them?
- And I raised them all with
their dads, with their father.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- But once they started cheating,
I kicked them niggas to the curb.
- [Mark] Your boys are how old now?
- My oldest son, Theodore, he's 34.
Pierre is 33, and my baby Unique, he's 27.
- [Mark] Have you ever been
arrested for doing this?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Have you ever been
arrested for doing this?
- No. Hell no.
- [Mark] Never been caught?
- Never.
- I always been caught,
you know, by selling drugs.
And like I told the judge,
why the dope is not in evidence?
- [Mark] Did you ever work with a pimp?
- [Treasure] Hell no, I'm a Renegade.
I keep my own mother
fucking money for my sons.
Fuck a pimp, 'cause pimps get fucked too.
If the price is right, a
nigga will get fucked too.
But you a sexy white man, though,
I don't know why them bitches
left you. They fucked up.
(Mark laughing)
(laughing) For real.
- [Mark] So you'll work
what hours typically?
What hours will you be out on Figueroa?
At night, during the day, changes?
- [Treasure] The week,
the early morning shift,
between two and six.
- [Mark] 2:00 and 6:00 AM.
- [Treasure] Yeah, the
early morning hours, AM.
- [Mark] These are men going to work
or coming home from?
- [Treasure] This mens going to work,
or getting off work. Truck drivers.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Treasure] Even men that
worked for the gas company,
the department of water and power, yeah.
- [Mark] And these guys are...
- [Treasure] They are blue collar men.
- [Mark] Yeah, and they're all races?
- [Treasure] Huh?
- White, Hispanic, black, everything?
- [Treasure] No, I only prefer two races.
Hispanic or Caucasian.
- [Mark] And that's it?
- [Treasure] I don't like black men.
I mean, I got all three of
my sons are by black men,
but black men don't know
how to treat a black queen,
so I prefer out of my race.
I ain't been with a black man in 27 years.
- [Mark] Wow.
- [Treasure] I don't
know what it feels like
for a black dick to go up in me.
I can masturbate my own self.
(laughing) What the fuck.
- [Mark] Does it get competitive out there
on the streets sometimes?
All the other girls?
- No, no.
- [Mark] Not for you.
- Not for me at all.
- [Mark] Your personality
kind of takes over.
- Yeah, uh huh.
- [Mark] I see that.
Do you feel like all the years working,
doing that for a living has changed--
- I never call, and I'll be
52 next month on the third,
I never had no STD or
them little creepy thing
they call the crabs
because if your dick
can't fit in a magnum,
I can't fuck with you.
I ain't got time to get lock jaw,
trying to suck a nigga dick.
What can't get up, won't get out.
No, I don't do that, no.
- [Mark] Do you feel like
all the years of doing this
has changed you?
- A hell of a lot.
- [Mark] How's that?
- To get my own money, fuck a pimp.
And these young girls
call these niggas daddy.
I called my father, father.
I don't call him daddy,
because it takes a hell
of a man to be a father.
Any nigga could be a daddy.
- [Mark] Is that it sounds like you
had a good relationship with your dad.
- I still do and he's 74 years old.
- [Mark] Whereas a lot of
the females I've talked to--
- Don't have their father.
They grew up in broken homes.
I grew up with a mom, with
a mother and a father.
- [Mark] And it seems like--
- I got principles and
morals about myself,
but the allowance that they was giving me,
it wasn't enough money,
so I had to be a renegade
and get my own money.
- [Mark] But it seems like
a lot of the other females
are maybe, looking for the pimp
to play out their dad role.
- They call them niggas daddy.
I ain't calling no nigga daddy.
I call my father, father.
I ain't calling no other nigga
daddy. You ain't my daddy.
My father, I could call his
number off the top of my head.
- [Mark] So what's the worst thing
about working the street?
- Just gotta be careful and cautious
who you get in the car with.
- [Mark] Use your intuition?
- Yeah. That gut feeling.
- [Mark] Have you had
bad things happen to you?
- Nope, I've never been raped,
stabbed, or none of that.
- [Mark] Most of the females
have been through all that.
- Never.
- [Mark] Why do you think you think
you've not had that happen?
- Because I'm a child of God,
and I feel like when something's wrong,
when a man, I look in their cars,
and if you don't have no door handles
something wrong with you.
I will kick they windows out
and I will jump out the window.
But thank God, I never
had that experience.
- [Mark] No one's even tried.
- Never, 'cause like I tell them,
you riding around the
streets looking for women,
you don't know who you fucking with.
Like I tell them, I'm a
crazy bitch from the Midwest.
It's either you are me.
- [Mark] You're from the Midwest?
- No, I tell them.
- [Mark] Oh, you tell them. (laughing)
- I'm from South Central.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I tell them I'm a crazy
bitch from the Midwest.
Do your family got life insurance for you?
You out here fucking with
me, trying to buy some pussy.
Go home and fuck your wife or
your girlfriend or whatever.
- [Mark] A female almost
needs your personality,
just to survive.
- I never been gang
raped, stabbed, or shot.
As you could see my body,
and I got three sons.
You know, I talk to a
person. I talk to them.
I don't talk at them.
Something going wrong in your household
that you out here on Figueroa
looking for a young woman,
and I'm 52 years old, and
I ain't ashamed of my age.
Like I tell these mother fuckers,
I'm not insecure with myself
or my mother fucking body.
I never been shot, stabbed,
gang raped, or none of that.
Thanks to the grace of God.
- [Mark] And your family
knows you're doing this?
- Yeah, they know it.
- [Mark] What about your sons?
- They don't like it, but oh well.
- [Mark] Do you think this is
just like an accepted thing
in South central? A lot of
women will do this, right?
- A lot of women do it for drugs,
but I do it to keep myself
up and the money that I make
I send to my three sons in the pen.
I don't know what other womens do,
but I do it for a reason. For my sons.
- [Mark] Your three sons are--
- In the pen.
- [Mark] For what?
- Oh my, uh, robbery, home invasion,
and robbing them mother
fucker that got all the money.
See, they learnt it from they mama.
I ain't taking nothing less.
- [Mark] Do you work on the neighborhoods
other than Figueroa?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Do you work
on other neighborhoods?
- They call me, I'm a call
girl. They just call me.
'Cause I really don't stand
out on the street no more.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- They just call me.
- [Mark] So you work through--
- Through my phone.
- [Mark] Yeah, got it.
- But I don't prefer black men,
so I'm putting on the camera
fuck black niggas, because
black men don't know
how to treat a black African queen.
I know what it's like to have things.
- [Mark] How do Hispanic or Caucasian men
treat you differently?
- Like a lady. They
opened the door for you.
When we go out to eat,
they put the little cloth over your lap.
They pull a chair out for me and all that.
Niggas don't do that.
And I got a pet peeve.
If your nails dirty, you need to take a,
if your nails and your toes is dirty,
the first thing hit the shower,
is your feet and your hands.
How are you going to try to
holler at me and your nails
and your feet is dirty and they stanky.
And then you sagging
and you got shit stains
all up your mother fucking drawers.
You didn't even wipe your ass today.
I don't deal with,
I prefer Caucasian or
Spanish, or Iranian men.
- [Mark] How much money
will you make in a night?
- Two Gs.
- [Mark] Really?
- Hell yeah.
- [Mark] That's good money.
- I ain't selling for nothing less,
'cause I got three sons I gotta
send money too in the pen.
They call me on the phone.
But I like you Mark, though,
you got some beautiful eyes.
You got some long legs.
You can just pick me up
and fuck me all the way
and we can walk around--
(both laughing)
You can walk me around the
house and just fuck me,
I wrap my legs around you
and I can just fuck you all day long.
- All right, Treasure.
I'll get your phone
number before we're done.
- [Treasure] Yeah.
(Mark laughing)
- [Treasure] Four, nine, four,
(bleeped), area code 323.
- [Mark] All right, you're fun.
Well, Treasure, thank you
so much for talking to me.
- Keep laying on that floor
like that, turn the camera off,
I'm gonna show you what I'ma do.
You got a bathroom in here?
- [Mark] I do.
- Good thing, I gotta pee pee.
- [Mark] I'll help you out.
- Can you turn this off?
- [Mark] Yeah.